موقع مقاطعه خيرسون واهميتها للجانبين
الروسي وكذلك الاوكراني نستعرضه في
التقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
مقاطعه خرسون جنوبيه اوكرانيا في موقع
استراتيجي تطل منه على بحر ازوف والاسود
كما تقع قرب مصبنه برو وبالتالي فهي تمثل
خط امداد حيويه يبلغ عدد سكان
اكثر من مليون شخص وتمتد على مساحه
28,000 و500 كم مربع تشكل جسرا بريا
لروسيا من اراضيها مرورا باقليم دومباز
الى شبه جزيره القرم التي تتصل بها وتتحكم
بمعظم مصادر مياه الشرب والزراعه التي
تغذي القرم تمتلك المدينه اكبر ميناء في
اوكرانيا لبناء السفن في البحر الاسود وهي
مركز الرئيسي للشاحن اضافه الى وجود صناعه
المهمه
وغيرها عدا عن كونها من اهم المناطق
السياحيه في
بدايه اكتوبر الماضي صدقت على اتفاقيه
انضمام اضافه
لعروس يا ريت اتحاديه وقد عين بوتين حاكما
لكل منطقه من تلك المناطق من هنا فانه قد
ينعكس تحول موازين القوه لصالح
الاوكرانيين في خرسون على المشهد في
الجنوب الاوكراني
[موسيقى]